These are the faces of women
who have come to represent progress.
Rwanda has led the world
in the levels of women in its parliament,
now for over a decade.
Nearly two thirds of Rwanda's parliament
is made up of women.
That's more than twice the global average.
Countries that have more women in power
tend to have a better
outcomes for development.
So, better outcomes for child mortality,
better outcomes for education.
Countries that have higher levels of women
in their government and also just general
better levels of gender
equality, more broadly
are more likely to be stable and secure.
But the origins of Rwanda's
high female representation
stem from the country's darkest moment.
Women must know that things have changed.
We can do, we can equally
do what men can do.
The whole world now wants
to learn from Rwanda
about gender, about women in Rwanda.
How are they developing?
What are they achieving?
While Rwanda leads the world
in female representation,
the motivations of the ruling
party have raised questions
about the true extent of women's power.
In April 1994, Rwandan
President Juvénal Habyarimana
was killed when his plane was shot down
near the country's capital, Kigali.
The assassination ignited ethnic tensions
between the majority, Hutu and
the minority, Tutsi tribes.
In 100 days of hatred, 800,000 died.
The violence would leave a
10th of the population dead.
While the conflict was
undoubtedly framed by ethnicity,
its effect on women was undeniable.
The genocide was planned,
not just killing but other things,
rape was a reward the leaders
gave to those who killed.
Most women had been gang raped.
That was very traumatic.
Some of them are mutilated.
Some of them have had children
born out of the rape.
Women were targeted
because of who they were.
And it shocked the world to
see that even your own husband,
whom you have given beautiful children
comes around and slaughters you
because you belong to that ethnic group.
Many others were, you know, disconnected
and kind of separated from their children,
from their families.
In spite of this horror,
it was women who would
rebuild the country.
It is now among the most
stable countries in Africa,
average incomes have tripled.
Educational, Healthcare, Tourism
and Trade are all improving dramatically.
Rwandan leader Paul Kagame
has been assailed by
international observers
for suppressing political
opponents and dissent,
sometimes violently.
But he and his ruling party, the RPF,
have also been praised for
stabilizing the country
and setting it on a course of recovery.
Part of this redevelopment
was enabling Rwandan women,
who had found themselves
taking on new roles
that had traditionally belonged to men.
Burying the dead, building homes,
as well as housing half a million orphans.
I'm always thinking of stories
that women have told me over the years
about how before the genocide,
they were a housewife
and they were living sort of,
you know, kind of day to
day, raising children,
cooking, caring for their plot of land
and how in the aftermath of the violence,
they found themselves alone
and completely realizing
that they needed to act,
they needed to pull people together.
They needed to do something
to be able to survive
the utterly abysmal and
horrible conditions of life.
Especially in rural communities
in the aftermath of the bloodshed.
Land has gone fallow,
massive displacement.
I mean, about 50% of the population
was displaced from their homes.
And so you see a total of
erosion of social networks.
You know, you no longer have
your community to be with.
You have to forge new networks
and forge new, you know,
ways of providing for yourself
and for your children and
for others in your community.
Just a few years after the violence,
women had formed an estimated 15,400
organizations across the country.
Initially, with a focus on
grief, trauma and support.
Mary Balikungeri founded
the Rwanda Women's Network.
In our safe space you could meet and cry,
talk about our challenges,
talk about issues that
really concerned us.
But at the same time, ask
ourselves, what should we do?
So out of that safe space,
women have learnt to plan, to organize,
to take awareness to their fellow women
and eventually to connect
to the whole thinking
to the whole political
thinking of the country.
And in that journey of
safety has given us the power
to know that you can change a society.
Some of these organizations
would evolve into vocational training
and profit-making businesses.
By joining together and
formalizing their structure,
groups could become eligible
for economic benefits
from NGOs or the government.
In the process of formalizing,
they established a
president, a vice president,
a secretary, a treasurer
and this provided really
a kind of a platform
for women's leadership
within these really nascent,
small, community organizations,
that then women could use
to kind of support their
increased engagement in politics.
This increasing engagement of women
in what had been a typical patriarchy,
would have a broader social impact.
From the clothes they wore,
to the businesses they started to run,
ideas of what women should
be were about to change.
When you look back
before the colonial era,
definitely women were, you
know, were very active,
active but yet invisible
and that's the typical patriarchal society
that most African countries are.
Patriarchy is a very hard system to undo.
It takes courage, it takes time,
because it is culturally grounded.
To begin undoing the system
there was one aspect of Rwandan society
that needed to change
quickly: land rights.
With more than 90% of Rwandans
dependent on agriculture
for their livelihood,
access was vital in the recovery.
Women's organizations mobilized
to take control of land
owned by deceased family members.
In 1999, the Succession Law was passed,
granting women the right to
inherit land and property
for the first time.
This would set the stage
for subsequent legislation
that established children's rights
and protection against
gender-based violence.
At the time they inheritance
laws were not there,
and so we had to fight for
it in order to make sure
that women are able to inherit
their husband's properties.
We want to be able to forcefully
put forward the women's needs,
because women's needs are not men's needs
and nobody will talk about women's needs
better than you as a woman.
With just 20 judges left
alive after the genocide,
more women also became
involved in Gacaca courts,
village-based justice proceedings
designed to try hundreds of thousands
accused of crimes during the genocide.
By 2001, about 35% of newly-elected
Gacaca judges were women.
Then in August, 2003, a new
constitution was written,
as well as committing to
fight the ideology of genocide
and eradicate ethnic divisions,
the constitution also
pursues gender equality.
It states that women are
granted at least 30% of posts
in decision making organs.
Research shows that 30%
is the critical mass
of women in power needed
to make a substantial
difference in politics.
In Rwanda, those seats
are elected by voters
from local women's councils,
but women are also able to contest seats
outside of this allocation.
In the first election after the genocide,
women won 48% of seats.
This really was, I think, evidence
of a broader swell of support,
both kind of from the political leadership
as well as from the grassroots,
for women's political participation
in this sort of new rebuilding Rwanda.
Those sorts of informal,
grassroots, self-help projects
became the foundation for building
a more engaged kind of political,
kind of population of women.
The narrative has changed,
before it was only a male-dominated space,
but now we are together in it.
So the more we continue to
engage ourselves with them
and the more we continue to reason them,
and that's why we said
the narrative is changing,
and it has changed for good.
By the next election, in 2013,
the number of women elected rose to 64%.
Led by Paul Kagame, the ruling party,
the Rwandan Patriotic Front
has made women's inclusion
a hallmark of its program
for post-genocide recovery
and reconstruction.
But despite the significant
steps in female empowerment
and broader development
following the genocide,
human rights advocates are highly critical
of the way in which Kagame's
party runs the country.
Freedom House ranks Rwanda as not free,
with concern about rights and liberties.
Human Rights Watch says the government
displays a marked intolerance
of the most basic forms of dissent.
Amnesty's International Rights Reports
in the lead up to the 2017 election
that talks about opposition politicians,
journalists, human rights
defenders being jailed,
physically attacked, even killed.
I think it's rubbish, absolute rubbish.
You reject that?
Rwanda is completely different
from what it was 25 years ago.
And although the RPF
welcomed women into politics,
critics suggest the motives
aren't as noble as once thought.
Women who were seen as less
complicit in the genocide
could be used to the party's advantage.
Many of the boldest and
most kind of fierce leaders
within civil society were
brought into government,
so that they could be, I think, greater
kind of policed in a way that is really,
has been detrimental
for the kind of growth
of democracy in Rwanda.
I think the notable thing
about the women seats,
is that they are not affiliated
with a political party,
so they are just women's seats.
And so critics have really suggested
that this has allowed
Rwandan Patriotic Front
to cement an even
greater political control
over the parliament.
Because while the number of
seats held by RPF members
is whatever it is, the number
of seats that are held by RPF
kind of supporters
and, you know, those closely
affiliated with the party
are often on the women's tickets
and so they're not actually,
they're not actually recorded
as being a member of a political party
while they're in office.
When we look at the cases of Diane Rwigara
or Victoire Ingabire, these are two women
that have dared to challenge
President Kagame for the presidency,
and both were met with extreme sanctions.
They were thrown in jail.
I think those cases
are really illustrative
in showing the limits
of the story of women's
empowerment in Rwanda.
We do see these kind of amazing levels
of women in government,
but at the same time,
what, you know, what power
does a parliament have
if they are completely under
the control of the Executive?
Women have power to the extent
that what they're
interested in and working on
does not conflict with
the goals of the regime.
So there have been some kind of notable,
I think, pieces of legislation,
especially around gender-based violence
that women parliamentarians
in Rwanda have pushed forward
and which have made important,
impressive sort of legislative
change in the country.
Despite this legislation,
levels of violence
against women remain high.
Estimates in 2010, found 41%
of women have experienced
some form of physical
violence since the age of 15,
rising to 56% for married women.
We see really the challenge
in assuming that women's
political empowerment
translates or trickles down
to women's empowerment, writ large, right?
We see remarkably high rates
of gender-based violence,
of intimate partner violence.
We see remarkably high rates
of women's economic disenfranchisement.
The story on Rwanda tends
to be quite polarized.
Just 25 years after
absolutely catastrophic
and horrific violence,
you see a country that hasn't
seen a return to bloodshed.
You see a country where there have been
profound increases in
longevity, in Health,
in Education, you know,
and that story is one
that really should be
celebrated and commended.
And then on the other hand,
this authoritarian state
that has completely
jeopardized its population's wellbeing
by shutting down dissent,
by conducting widespread
extra judicial killings.
These two stories are mutually compatible.
They are both true.
And I think the, you
know, the reality is that
Rwanda's developmental
progress has been made possible
by its authoritarian nature, right?
Rwanda's success, in terms
of not having another
outbreak of violence has been possible
because of its massively robust
military and security apparatus.
Some of the gains women have made
are undermined by the
authoritarian nature of the state.
Disproportionate numbers of wealthy,
foreign-born Tutsi women
sit at the top of the table.
Which means new forms of inequality
are developing in Rwanda,
impacting the incredible
progress women made
in the immediate
aftermath of the violence.
Rwanda leads the world
when it comes to the
number of women in power,
but it's only one part of the
bigger picture of equality.
For me, the real lesson of Rwanda is that,
getting women into politics
is only one of many
things we must do to actually,
you know, increase women's
power and more importantly,
dismantle forms of
oppression against women.
If the level of women in government
is not matched by a corresponding,
kind of strong women's movement
rooted in civil society,
then the women in government
are almost always going to be tokenized.
That sort of corresponding
need for women in government
and kind of the
restructuring of the economy
of kind of the kind of patriarchal roots
of the family and of society
and of changing kind of
the systems of governance as well,
that's the way that we build
a more gender equal future.
This process we are going
through as a country,
I call it a rebirth.
I must say that Rwanda,
when you compare it to
other African countries,
we are definitely fortunate
because we have a system,
a system that responds
to the needs of women.
So we keep reminding ourselves
that we worked for it and we deserve it.
We are now saying we need to raise
our sons and daughters differently.
We've come to understand
because we have enjoyed
the new opportunities
that the new Rwanda offers,
and doing what is undoable, it's tough.
Let's continue but at the same time,
make sure that the generation to come
sees things differently.